hey guys we're going to talk about how to
lower uric acid uric acid basically is a
byproduct to proteins and it can leak into the
joints and create a lot of like arthritic type
pain especially in the gout the big toe and
the lower part of the feet and also turn into
kidney stone so it can be very very painful
so what causes that mainly is high-fructose
corn syrup and that's a lot of soft drinks a
lot of the junk foods out there you probably
know people who consume that but I know you don't
consume that too much sugar will do that kidney
problems fasting can actually increase your
uric acid in your body ketosis can do it as
well and diuretics okay an excessive consumption
of meat so these are things you just want to look
at but here's the remedy it's potassium citrate
if you took potassium citrate you could knock
out uric acid pretty fast it helps neutralize
that and so you want to start cleaning up this
this stuff right here of course don't get off
the ketosis don't stop fasting you clean this
up start adding potassium but you could also get
it from a lot of vegetables and that's why when
I recommend ketosis you know you're switching
from running on glucose to running on fats okay
when you do that you're changing your whole fuel
system and I recommend adding a lot of vegetables
to that because your body you use pH is going
to start becoming acidic you're going to get
rid of a lot of your gas food crystals and so
you want to have a lot of vegetables to flush
all that out of there if you do a ketosis diet
without vegetables you're going to end up with
probably gout and kidney stones so you want to
consume that so anyway I want to bring up that
point and go ahead and start doing that and thank
you so much for watching hey guys thank you so
much for watching please click the subscribe
button and I will see you in the next video